hello and welcome to a special edition
of spectator tv the prime minister has
resigned
what happens next to discuss i'm joined
by fraser nelson isabel hardman
and here's what the prime minister had
to say
it is clearly now the will
of the parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister and i've agreed with segren
brady the chairman of our back bench mps
that the process of choosing that new
leader should begin now and the
timetable will be announced next week
and i've today appointed a cabinet to
serve as i will until a new leader is in
place
isabel can you just bring us up to date
because we've had a live blog going
yesterday that's had to run into today
posts going up around midnight because
the resignations have just
not stopped but yet it has now reached
the point where the prime minister has
decided to leave
yeah so i think it was safe to sleep at
about 2 a.m last night and then all
started up again at about six
with ministers continuing to resign that
the decisive moment was when nadim
zahawi who has been chancellor for i
think it's 33 hours 36 hours
placed boris johnson in checkmate
by publishing a letter on treasury
headed note papers making clear that he
hadn't resigned
calling on the prime minister to quit
saying that he had made this advice
private initially um to the prime
minister last night in number 10 as we
know
but that the prime minister had ignored
this advice that he was making it public
but because he wasn't resigning what he
was effectively saying was look i'm not
going to collapse your government you
have to collapse your government because
you if you sack a chancellor
and then you pick what i mean there's no
one to pick who's going to become your
chancellor now um then you you are
collapsing the government so it was
basically game over for boris johnson we
also had michelle donald and the
education secretary quitting which did
mean that there was only one minister
left in that department and that was an
unpaid pier
as opposed to any mps and so even though
chris heaton harris the chief whip had
been telling boris johnson since early
evening yesterday that he was not going
to be able to fill the spaces in his
government he was not going to have a
functioning government and actually
indeed the more junior whips were busy
cancelling
uh pieces of legislation that were going
through the commons today
boris johnson didn't actually
acknowledge that psychologically until
today fraser
last night you had a situation where
there was a cabinet minister delegation
the delegation fell into two camps
nadine doris for example was not in the
camp trying to get the prime minister to
resign um but it failed to do the job at
the time yet clearly overnight the prime
minister had a change of heart what do
you think has led him to change his mind
i think for a moment of madness he
thought that he could brazen out in his
head he was elected by millions of
people and could not be deposed by a
small number of tories so this by the
way is a flaw with his whole premiership
he had a presidential model in his mind
the idea that he had the personal man
that he could apply he wanted the other
guys were only there because because of
him and by the way he's quite right to
say but it wasn't for him personally a
good number of these tories would not be
in parliament there would be no majority
there probably would be no brexit but
ultimately we've got a parliamentary
democracy you cannot run it as a
presidency as borla johnson tried to do
and i think what really changed for him
was when even the people he newly
appointed turned against him so he
thought oh it's not just simply a
question of filling in because you think
okay there's enough psychopaths from a
tory party to fill these vacancies
although i think we're not we're to 52
the number of resignations you need
quite a lot of tories to do 52
psychopaths
even
the new ones were saying to him actually
you've got to go so nadeem zahawi um i
imagine that deems how he probably did
when he accepted the job of chancellor
that might have been a good point to say
by the way i don't think he should
continue his leader i think he dropped
that bombshell a few hours later uh but
you know when michelle donnelly quit
quit his education secretary um after
you know less than 48 hours in the job i
think it became clear even to boris
johnson that if he tried to plug these
holes in his government he'd end up with
the same thing they'd all be um taking
the job and telling him to go and then
quitting so it was unsustainable
so what was happening was that the um i
spoke to a cabinet member um a couple of
days ago saying look we don't want to
take this to a parliamentary vote
against him we want him to take the hint
and that hint
was first of all um
gentle but it was a little bit stronger
in the form of a leadership sort of form
of vm the confidence motion
and
so you what you ended up was stronger
and stronger versions of the hint
right up until the point where there was
like 10 50 fewer ministers in the
government even then boris was saying oh
this is actually a good thing i can slim
down government so i can have a more
efficient government well you could have
a very efficient education department
with no ministers in it at all a very i
mean that was actually a yes minister
sketch that abolished education
department he'd actually done that by
accident you had michael gove's
department where he fired gove and gives
two other ministers that quit
and what was happening i think was that
he was heading into donald trump
territory
and he intends to be a public figure for
many years after this he tends to do
television to do books to do
highly paid newspaper columns
well all sorts of things and that sort
of slightly depends on your reputation
and he was very quickly soiling his
reputation
and a way that would have seriously
undermined his future earning potential
and indeed his reputation trump will
forever be defined i think by the
leaving of the white house and boris
johnson was in grave danger of being
defined by his refusal to work within
democratic norms and way outside what
most people would regard as democratic
decency and isabel let's talk about that
potential damage to boris johnson's
reputation
and because ultimately
i think the sense last night when it was
clear that he was not moving and some
quite interesting briefings uh to
various places such as the sun so you
know um they have to be uh dip their
hands in blood hands and blood
they're gonna force him out of there
um
effectively now you have a situation
where prior to him choosing to go it
looked as though the most likely way out
for the prime minister was next week a
new 1922 executive they could bring in
new rules there could be a confidence
vote monday night tuesday
is he going to get any credit or
anything for choosing to go at this
point because we're already hearing the
prime minister's like to stay on through
the summer until the autumn and a new
leader is announced but has he done so
much damage that enemies don't want that
to happen
i think conservative mps are quite
psychologically damaged by the past uh
few days and i include in that people
who
even up to the weekends were still pro
boris who have just been
uh
upset
uh no upset's not even a strong enough
word i mean i've seen so many of them in
tears
deeply disturbed by the way he behaved
the way he didn't take their advice
the way they feel he's embarrassed
himself i've gone slightly mad quite a
few of them
said and i was talking to to one of his
staunch allies who's worked incredibly
hard to try to turn things around to try
to keep the party on track to try to
keep the prime minister on track
and he was saying just look at how my
colleagues still talk about the
departure of margaret thatcher with
tears in their eyes the damage this is
going to do to our party for a very long
time cannot be underestimated and they
they were very much of the view that
boris johnson needed to go by that point
but
they
they were very concerned about the
damage that this was going to do to
their colleagues to the party's
reputation um and to the sort of the
general interactions within the party as
well there's a lot of toxicity now in
the party and so i'm not sure he's going
to get very much credit
um
for
going
now rather than waiting to choose
obviously he would you know
it would have been horrific had he uh
stayed on even until the afternoon but
um
but but i think the damage is really
done and i think there's going to be a
lot of um in the post-mortem to this
there's going to be a lot of um
people saying that he's done irreparable
damage to the party and fraser there's
some talk about an interim leader but
boris johnson doesn't want that he wants
to stay in 10 downing street what do you
think's the most likely outcome
well of course dominic grab could take
over as as deputy leader and and boris
johnson i don't think
first of all i don't think we need to
wait until october of a new leader there
is a faster timetable which goes as like
this that people start declaring their
hand between now and
sunday and then maybe at this spectator
summer party well we're having a summer
party this evening i imagine that's
going to be the first hustings the
unofficial one
and and then of course the mps decide
now what you can do there is if you want
have you know
it's like it's a knockout competition so
you would have it all collect votes
release successful ones knocked out etc
now you could do two or three of these a
day if you wanted you could whittle it
down to two candidates by the end of
next week now once you've got those two
candidates you could then take it to the
party more nationally and you needn't by
the way allow that to drag on all summer
you could tell them we want you to do it
in a month or even two or three weeks so
there's no reason why we couldn't have a
new prime minister within a month as the
tories are demonstrating with the 1922
committee they can rewrite the rules any
time they want really and right now
we this isn't a party in opposition
that's got luxury of a long time to lick
its wounds and think what it wants to do
with itself this is supposedly a
government at the time of economic
crisis at a time of war
and i think the tories collectively owe
it to the country to compensate for the
chaos which they have collectively
unleashed by coming up with some kind of
order now
and that would mean getting their their
ducks in a row being able to not waste
time on this would we now
we say in the cover story this week and
we've done the cover story on the
leadership um because we figured at the
weekend but the time we came out on
saturday boris would probably have gone
and that we'd be looking at the
leadership candidates but we point out
how little is known for example of ben
wallace ben wallace is the defense
secretary now he is one of the main
candidates severe bookmakers have got
him as a sort of second or third
favorite and what does he think about
anything other than defense nobody
really knows you've got penny mordent
who right now as we speak is the
bookmaker's favorite and you might think
that's crazy she's such a minor figure
wouldn't it be that he was a hawaii or
she's tsunac one of the bigger beasts
but tory leadership contests are never
like that they're always won by people
who've got the fewest enemies not the
most admirers it tends to be a kind of
um a combination with sort of a
tarantino-esque sort of squid game to
makes my film metaphors a bit where
people get taken out violently so they
think okay who's the frontrunner okay
let's stop him so we might see nadim
zahawi emerge as a frontrunner and then
anybody but zahawi kemp tried to take
him out remember thatcher wasn't anybody
when she became a tory party leader
nobody took her seriously and john major
wasn't really taken seriously as a
legion people assumed it'd be a
hazeltine figure so the trajectory of a
trend of tory party leadership contest
is to throw up somebody unexpected
and that's the stage we're now at
it's about when it comes to that
unpredictable and potentially quite
vicious leadership contest that we are
heading towards it's been interesting
watching the various camps in terms of
the cabinet ministers so clearly you've
had those who quit early on which is
soon excited javid and then you've had
those who have quit belatedly um i'm not
even sure from the demonstration
and then you've got those such as ben
wallace who have stayed in cabinet who i
think put out a message today's um a
long forces to raise coffee we don't
think is the leadership contender but
you never know and effectually saying
don't criticize us for remaining in
cabinet there are some really important
jobs and the briefs um are we starting
to see them almost kind of get their
their lines out there is to justify
either their distance or their closeness
of boris johnson yeah i think that's a
really good point that that a lot of the
campaigning over the next few days is
going to involve people as you say
explaining why i did what i did um why i
stayed to ensure that you know the war
in ukraine continued to be supported by
the you know by the british government
why i decided to quit because i needed
my integrity to be intact even though
i'd you know gone on the airwaves
defending this prime minister for the
past six months um so i think that's
going to be quite um
i think quite entertaining actually um i
think it's going to have quite a lot of
interesting pleading and then you're
obviously going to have the
the backbenchers like steve baker um who
has made very clear that he wants to
stand and is going to be the sort of
erg candidate you've got
one of the most surprising um
uh announcements was the attorney
general um surely braverman who
uh attorney generals tend to sort of
operate as kind of quasi politicians
when they're in that job and sort of
rise above all of this but uh instead
she uh went on pesten last night
declared her candidacy and then did a
rogue media round um which you kind of
have to respect in the currency she's
the first one to properly declare though
yeah and i think there is a kind of
first mover advantage here we've had
these tories moaning for i don't know
how long about how much we don't like
boris johnson but what i haven't heard
from any of them even in private is what
or who would do better there seem to be
no new ideas right now now this is why i
think this could actually get worse for
the tories because boris johnson has
occupied
this conversation he sucked the oxygen
out of it so much so but nobody seems
able to discuss anything other than him
uh but what is like what is going to be
done about inflation is it how is the
tory party going to cut spending if it
wants low taxes if so where
nobody is rushing to come out with any
answers to this so it could well be that
boris johnson is a symptom rather than
the cause of tory malays and that when
he goes they'll be stuck with the fact
that they've got a whole bunch of
problems and not a single single serious
solution if that happens then we are
looking not so much at regicide but
suicide
we've had so much policymaking that's
been about survival and the survival of
the prime minister that as fraser says
that there hasn't actually been much
talk of sort of first principles and why
the party is doing what it's doing and i
think actually this uh this relationship
that conservative party has had with
boris johnson i think a lot of people
are going to come out of it saying i
can't believe i propped him up for this
long a bit like you know when a couple
splits up and suddenly they realize that
they really hated each other and it
takes quite a long time to unwind
thank you isabel thank you fraser and
thank you for watching
you